[Musique]
le président du Département Cyril
Melchior et Pierrick Robert président de
la Chambre de commerce et d'industrie
réunion ont signé une déclaration
d'intention pour renforcer
l'accompagnement des bénéficiaires du
RSA créateur d'activités ce mardi 31
janvier
nous avons en commun de vouloir le
développement de Lille et qui dit
développement dit aussi création
d'emplois création d'activités soutien
aux entreprises et on le sait qu'à la
Réunion beaucoup d'entreprises sont des
entreprises familiales et il y a pour
ceux qui nous concerne les entreprises
agricoles et j'insiste beaucoup pour
dire qu'avec le président
Eric Robert nous voulons
consolider toute la partie
transformation des produits avec une
industrie agroalimentaire plus
développée de façon à donner des
garanties de revenus aux planteurs aux
producteurs de la Réunion pour le
président Pierrick Robert cette
coopération annonce de belles
perspectives pour l'insertion
professionnelle
aujourd'hui nous travaillons déjà avec
le département sur différents sujets la
Chambre de commerce que je représente
veut encore je dirais
on va pouvoir justement démultiplier
encore plus d'actions ensemble pour que
nous puissions mettre vraiment en avant
notre territoire le besoin de nos
territoires le besoin de la population
réunionnaise et également faire
correspondre cela avec les attentes du
monde économique était également présent
à l'indique crescendo président de la
CCI France en séjour à la Réunion pour
quelques jours
la macroéconomie n'existe plus
ça veut dire de très très loin imaginer
que des solutions vont satisfaire à tout
le monde ça ne marche pas et moi je suis
un homme de micro-économie ça veut dire
que il faut intégrer ces micro-économies
des territoires il faut les dynamiser il
faut les accélérer et c'est cette somme
de microéconomique qui fait la grandeur
et la force de l'économie d'un pays
voilà le partenariat prévoit également
des engagements réciproques pour le
développement la structuration et la
professionnalisation du secteur des
services à la personne
[Musique]